[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're discussing the release date for
the highly anticipated harry potter game
hogwarts legacy
to date the trailer for hogwarts legacy
has amassed over 29 million views and
just four months after official gameplay
footage was unveiled the hogwarts legacy
state of play video has amassed over 10
million views
i think it's safe to say that this game
is getting some attention
but one thing we haven't gotten yet is a
definitive release date originally all
we were told was 2022 and then
eventually we were given a new vague
release date of holiday 2022
well it's now august and we haven't seen
anything
but rest assured there is finally some
good news surrounding hogwarts legacy a
new definitive release date has been
announced the upcoming game which will
be released on multiple platforms is now
scheduled for a february 10 2023 release
date for playstation xbox and pc
this news comes from the official
hogwarts legacy twitter account
hogwarts legacy will launch on february
10 2023 for playstation xbox and pc the
nintendo switch launch date will be
revealed soon the team is excited for
you to play but we need a little more
time to deliver the best possible game
experience a release date for hogwarts
legacy on nintendo switch has yet to be
announced as noted in the tweet the
hogwarts legacy twitter account also
retweeted a tweet from the warner
brothers games avalanche twitter which
includes a video message from the
developers of the game
i'm chandler wood community manager here
at avalanche software i'm at our studio
in salt lake city to let you know that
hogwarts legacy will now launch on
february 10 2023 for playstation xbox
and pc the nintendo switch launch date
will be revealed soon
you may be disappointed that the game's
been pushed out of 2022 but we're
excited to finally give you a release
date you can look forward to
we're excited about what we're creating
here at the studio and we just need a
little bit more time to deliver the best
possible experience to everyone
we appreciate your patience as we
continue to work on the game and we
can't wait to bring you hogwarts legacy
early next year
are you all excited for the game want me
to cover it anything i've missed leave a
comment down below until next time
remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]
you